the White House is panicking and
desperately trying to stop Donald
Trump's tax returns from being sent to
the House of Representatives one of the
first members of Congress that I met
when I started doing the David Pakman
show is Richard Neal from Massachusetts
and he was actually my congressman where
the show was originally located out in
Western Massachusetts and we're the
first studio wasn't where I lived
he was our congressman so to speak until
the districts were redrawn but he's
always been a friend of the show and
he's not one of these celebrity
congressmen he's not the most
progressive on every issue but he does
do the right thing often and last week
he formally requested Donald Trump's tax
returns from the last six years as well
as Donald Trump's business tax returns
from the Internal Revenue Service from
the Treasury and this is how it works
there's a law from 1924 which gives
House and Senate committees that deal
with tax writing the right to request
specific tax returns from the IRS in
this case congressman Richard Neal is on
the House Ways and Means Committee
Richard Neal has given a deadline of
April 10th for these to be provided to
the House of Representatives Ways and
Means Committee it's really not easy to
block these requests unless you have
really good reasons so this is why
elections matter right now that
Democrats controlled the house and
control House committees this is one of
the things that they can do Donald Trump
has claimed that the reason he hasn't
released his tax returns is because he's
under audit now it's been years now
being under audit doesn't preclude or
prevent you in any way from releasing
your tax returns even a Fox News
contributor even other people associated
directly with Donald Trump like his
chief of staff have said being under
audit whether it's true or not it's not
really a good reason not to release your
tax returns but regardless Donald Trump
hasn't done it and more importantly it's
been disputed whether Donald Trump's tax
returns are even under audit you might
remember that Michael Cohen at his
testimony under oath said that it's just
something Trump says it's not true and
certainly there's never been any
evidence provided
that indicates Donald Trump actually is
under audit so now the Trump White House
is in this predicament where they are
running out of legal options to prevent
the release of Donald Trump's tax
returns to the House of Representatives
Ways and Means Committee Richard Neal
has used a completely very cool very
legal to quote Donald Trump method to
request those tax returns and the Trump
administration is planning to go to
Trump's Attorney General William Bar to
prevent to use the Justice Department to
prevent the release of Trump's taxes to
the House Ways and Means Committee will
this work I don't know it's going to be
tough they are clearly very desperate
and if you go back and actually look at
the 1924 law it says nothing about the
White House gets to decide whether
they're ok with the release of the
president's taxes to the House Ways and
Means Committee there's nothing about
the president's hand-picked attorney
general gets to get involved it's very
cut and dry they have the right to
request the tax returns from the
Treasury Department so there's a couple
different issues here that I want to
talk about first of all why do we want
to see Trump's tax returns maybe people
have sort of forgotten about that issue
since for so long it was a foregone
conclusion that we weren't going to get
to see them well number one we want to
see if the president is a liar on this
issue we know he's a liar we want to see
if he's a liar on this particular issue
we want to see if he's a criminal and we
believe in transparency which Donald
Trump claims to believe in I've said all
along though I am very skeptical of the
idea that Donald Trump's taxes are going
to expose criminality of any kind the
most likely scenario
I believe Pat is that trumps taxes would
expose he's not nearly as rich as he
says he is and potentially that he pays
very very little in terms of a federal
tax rate I don't know if you disagree
but I don't think criminality is going
to be exposed by looking at Donald
Trump's taxes I don't think that Trump
is overly concerned with it being
exposed that he's not paying so much in
federal taxes like he should be paying
more
because Republican voters aren't going
to care about that Trump himself says
that you know it's it's my job to pay as
little in taxes as I possibly can that's
my obligation to myself to my business
to my family I think he is worried
though that the public's going to find
out that he's not as rich as he claimed
to be and that would kind of debunk him
being the savior that America needed
during 2016 he was the successful
business guy who was going to bring the
country so much success that he was able
to achieve yeah I actually think that
Trump is enough of an egomaniac that he
would work this hard to keep his taxes
secret merely so it doesn't get revealed
that he's not nearly as rich as he
claims to be now what once again what's
the pattern here
Trump is totally innocent but the Moller
report needs to be kept secret and in
fact during the entire investigation the
investigation is illegal bad a
witch-hunt and needs to be stopped
Trump's taxes are absolutely great but
they absolutely have to be kept secret
Trump was a genius brilliant student but
he threatened schools with lawsuits
through his then tie then personal
attorney Michael Cohen if his
transcripts or grades get out if you
think that this is normal and okay
you're a part of the problem and you're
part of the Trump cult of personality
that I spoke about last week and you
know what I would actually respect some
of these right-wingers more if they said
and rather than pretending that there's
nothing here that we should be looking
at in Donald Trump's taxes rather than
pretending that this is not yet another
one of Donald Trump's promises made that
he hasn't kept I would respect
right-wingers and Trump is more if they
said listen I like Trump's immigration
policy I like Trump's tax policy and I
like Trump's foreign policy but he
simply must release his tax returns
because he promised to do it and because
we need to be sure that there's nothing
disturbing in there I'm gonna be doing
the exact same thing on Friday I'm
taking an audience question about Bernie
Sanders is tax returns okay I like
Bernie I agree with many of his policies
he's in the top three in terms of who I
am potentially going to be supporting in
the 2020 Democratic primary but
said he'd release his taxes and he's got
a release his taxes and every day they
dated he does every day that he doesn't
tongue-tied here it is a growing problem
for Bernie Sanders and I can take a
nonpartisan perspective on that Bernie
said he'd release on Trump said he'd
release him neither has they both need
to so just come forward I welcome
trumpets call in during live calls or
write me an email tell me that you were
able to put partisanship aside and say
Trump Scotto released his taxes and he's
got to do it right away